à propos de santé et on revient en
france cette première médicale à
l'hôpital de rouen une valve cardiaque a
été implanté sans intervention
chirurgicale le patient était trop
faible pour cela en fait il était
considéré comme perdu la valve a été
glissée dans une veine fémorale est
amenée jusqu'au coeur reportage jérôme
cheval pierre bonté joseph pas seulement
venir mais à dormir manger à table
donc c'est reparti comme avant
et c'est reparti comme avant on a envie
de parler d'un véritable miracle médical
il y a huit jours le jeune était mourant
une valve de son coeur ne fonctionnait
plus pour la changer une opération à
coeur ouvert et et nécessaire quatre
services de chirurgie ont refusé de
prendre le risque de l'opérer depuis
deux jours eugène va mieux il a une
valve tout neuf et tout ça sans
chirurgie l'exploit des cardiologues
c'est d'avoir réussi à introduire cette
minuscule valve en lieu et place de la
valve défaillante
les médecins ont introduit une sonde par
une veine du plie de l'aisne direction
l'oreillette droite
la sonde a ensuite traversé la paroisse
cardiaque oreillettes gauche ventricule
gauche pour enfin atterrir à la base de
l'aorte
une première qui redonne l'espoir de
traiter des patients pour lesquels
aucune solution n'existe actuellement
le but de cette technique sc2
apporter une solution thérapeutique et
régions qui sont considérés par les
médecins et par les chirurgiens comme
non opérable ou à très haut risque
chirurgical
alors les gens qui sont non opérable
peuvent être des gens qui sont trop âgés
pour être opérés ou qui ont des mets des
maladies associées grave qui font que le
risque opératoire est élevé l'exploit
médicale s'est doublée d'un exploit
technique la valve de gênes a été
fabriquée en urgence le week-end dernier
par une société israélienne est acheminé
par avion jusqu'à rouen